davon ist wie gesagt ein wasserfall und
ich weiß nicht ob ich mir treten werde
dafür nicht
wir sind auf dem parkplatz eines
baumarktes ordentlich müssen wir diesmal
nicht im wald kennen das wäre eine ganz
geile alternative eine kleine
abwechslung bei elia wird uns jetzt auch
sofort die nächste anweisung geben und
dann sehen wir mal was wir in diesem
baumarkt machen dürfen wir wollten eine
challenge die kriegt sie gegen baum 850
euro und 30 minuten zeit um alles zu
besorgen was diesmal einfluss braucht
werde ist das erstes erreicht gewinnt
diese folge was hat er sich dabei
gedacht der fachebene aufnahme gemacht
ich bin euch die mal eben kurz ein also
das wetter ist anders
ihr habt ist so krank geregnet ist wieso
kranke strömungen geben womit 50 euro
mit 50 euro
ein floß baut ein rennen fahren letzten
estate jetzt geht es los wir geben in
verschiedene richtungen und ich will als
erstes mal zu den regenrinnen klingt
bescheuert aber der mobilität dass ich
das quasi unter eine platte montiert
weil die dinger sollten eigentlich die
luft drin hätten so viele leute dass
meine bisherige ausbeute noch die
zweiten diesen regenrinnen quasi das
sind insgesamt ungefähr 25 euro mit
platte und irgendwas was noch mehr
auftrieb gibt hier vorne bevor in der
glaube styropor sorgt sich nicht
wasserfalls doch bin ich verloren weil
mein plan ist jetzt eine platte
untendrunter styropor dann diese beiden
bahnen waren und alles mit panzer tab
fest geben und dann irgendwas ein paar
denn ich muss mich daran halten überlegt
ob ich statt einer holzplatte
tatsächlich spüren
das ist wie styropor und
widerstandsfähiger vorne wer nicht wagt
der nicht gewinnt in der pflicht die
regierung kein holz das macht mich
leichter von schneller minus bei 32 eur
99 hier ist es und es schmerzt wirklich
10 eur 990 hat aber ich brauche
unbedingt so wenig kohle jetzt noch am
ende übrig das muss irgendwas finden ich
glaube ich habe meine die rettende idee
die sieht also den hof auf dem wir das
machen ist nicht besonders tief könnte
mir also wie in venedig barriere sondern
starb holen um nicht mit dem vorwärts
bewegen ich glaube genau das werde ich
machen
das ist so schlau ist so schlau und
herzig verkennt ist euch anschauen 49
eur 770 das alles ganz ehrlich ich habe
einfach keine chance hat das so perfekt
ausgereiften gespannt ich natürlich als
erstes wieder im auto packt alles die
sachen sind übertrieben heute gehe ich
glaube schon führung
wen haben wir denn da ob das noch
rechtzeitig war dave das noch
rechtzeitig wahr was die vierziger zeit
wie eure weniger wer danach noch meinen
sie fressen
okay okay das ist eine andere leute
übernimmt bekommt er die ab meint
abgesehen was ich eigentlich noch gar
nicht richtig angeschaut du deinen drei
kilo auftrieb abstieg bis 120 liter
volumen
im gegensatz zu deinen missbrauchs aber
auch weil die holzplatte genommen hast
ich habe styrodur ich brauche sie wissen
damit geschwindigkeit auch wenn du weißt
schon dass es ein rennen ist ja das was
ich dann auch mal was hier so ein
bisschen traurig herumliegt sind meine
utensilien und ihr seht schon im
hintergrund den reißenden fluss auf den
wir uns begeben werden ist die sie bei
bretter noch einbrechen könnte glaube
ich ein bisschen schwer werden was du
dir vorgenommen haben könnte ich glaube
ich ein bisschen wenig auftrieb haben
was zu dir vorgestellt
das wird glaube ich sehr sehr spannend
leute ich stecke jetzt mal eben meine
sachen zusammen und halten auch wenn du
bist von ihr sein wird bei mir ist sogar
mit 34 handgriffe dann habe ich das auch
schon fertig ich mache das zur bombe
botschafter innen drin ist eine dichtung
und das bewegt sich selbst wenn ich will
nicht raus kann wirklich nicht glauben
dass genug auf symposien
wenn es nicht genug auftrieb hat damit
stecken lassen es ist ehrlich ein
bisschen schwer haben wir jetzt gedacht
habe ohne dass hierfür meine beiden
rohre gab es gerade heben gegenüber date
schon zugegeben die sind schwerer als
ich befürchtet hatte
da ist halt nur luft und ich hoffe dass
es trotzdem irgendwie reicht an auftrieb
und davidson später drüber lacht sich
ein arbeiter ist die reinste frechheit
da hinten mit seinen grotten eimern
alter heute ist die zeit gekommen um in
führung zu gehen vor dem und guck mal
wie schön dass da hinten aussieht und
das mal kein anblick ist vor dem es spaß
macht dave abzuziehen
denn bevor wir weiterbauen gucken dass
ich erst mal gemeinsam den fluss an die
sieg auf der wir heute unser rennen
abhalten werden geht hier einfach super
runter dann sind wir auch schon da ich
glaube wir starten gleich von dieser
insel hier im fluss drin ihr seht nur
schon hier vorne ist wirklich nicht tief
und ihr seht auch hier vorne zum
beispiel sie hat ordentlich strömung man
jetzt schnell panzer tape um alles rum
und befestige alles für ready to go away
hat jetzt gerade hier den akkuschrauber
geholt aber er ist sehr gut weil der
kann das glaubst du du kriegst die
schrauben damit ein in dieses hartholz
musste daten noch mal los ziehen und den
cup holen weil ich hatte da nicht so
richtig für mehr dass die
styroporplatten versetzt sind also dass
hier das eine stück weiter raus steht
nach der anderen seite das andere das
hat aber zur folge dass das archiv ist
ich muss also die untere oder die obere
platte anpassen wollen wir das hier auf
meine konstruktion darum ist der ist und
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen darf sieht
nach ein bisschen mehr auf 182
regenrinnen styrodur das ist alles und
ich werde jetzt mal vorsichtig sind
testwagen werde ich mich da vielleicht
braucht begebe ja also jetzt regt mich
auf jeden fall aber davon welche
ausgegangen habe echt nicht viel platz
muss ich sagen da gleich nicht
herunterzufallen könnte aussterben
einfluss steht jetzt auf jeden fall ich
habe mich auch gegen diese schau 4
entschieden weil ich glaube mit dem stab
bin ich einfach besser bedient bei dem
geringen wasserstand und dave hat hier
drüben sei
helle konstruktion aber ich glaube das
wird das rennen machen ich meine sie
winzig aus aber es wird viel schneller
sein als dieses ding wenn man darf nicht
vergessen wir machen hier ein rennen wir
machen hier keinen sonntagsausflug und
elia hat uns zu einem rennen
aufgefordert und wenn mir nicht sicher
ob du dave seiner konstruktion dafür
richtig gewachsen bist meine könnten
natürlich auseinander fallen aber deine
könnte langsam sein habe das auto
geparkt und sind barfuß unterwegs ist
wirklich sehr schön hier hat sich eine
strecke ausgesucht die genau von einer
brücke zu einer anderen brücke geht wie
laufen jetzt den weg schnell hoch bis
wir bei unseren flüssen sind bringt
jetzt die boote ins wasser starten dann
von der insel und das habe ich euch noch
nicht gezeigt ich habe mir was
mitgebracht aus der ersten folge du hast
die ganze zeit gedacht er könne gewinnen
aber ich habe heim vorteil
ihr dachtet vielleicht dass das bisher
ein cooles video war aber leute es wird
jetzt richtig scheiße ich habe nämlich
nicht nur die kamera falsch eingestellt
sondern der ton ist auch beschissen
viel spaß und ich bin dem wasser
mainburg tiger hat das tower das wasser
um mein gott bei der fahrende gegen
diesen sonnenuntergang und ihr könnt ihr
nicht die ganze zeit sehen guckt euch
diesen traum haben den beinamen gewinnen
euch schon mal in dieser
kameraeinstellung und alle meine
nasenhaare ich schwimme aber falls es
euch bis jetzt nicht aufgefallen ist ich
liege auf einem floß ich weiß nicht ob
das erlaubt war zwischen trauerspiel in
diesen fällen haben wir locker fünf
stunden investiert führen
ich stecke einfach fest seht ihr das
naja dave auch wissen wer hat dann gold
gewonnen oder verloren ja verloren
ich glaube unsere klose auch wenn man
viel schmaler ins schwimmen genau den
gleichen stellen die hilfe in den körper
hinein eine heimat verloren
das an leute ich habe einmal anders geil
ich bin erster freundin fremd wirkt auf
hochtouren
davon ist wie gelassen wasser fällt und
ich weiß nicht ob ich mir treten werde
dafür nicht
[Musik]
diese wasserfälle waren wirklich keinen
spaß
es gab insgesamt 23 auf dieser strecke
und jedes mal wurde man wirklich mega
schnell hat man das gefühl das ist raus
auseinanderreißen werden ausgelacht es
kommen nacheinander gebrochen und da
kommen langsam dem cyber-angriff ich
möchte die restmüll sammler für dave ich
gewinne gerade
ich kann also dann meint nur keine ganz
entspannt aber ganz entspannt haben
irgendwelche ideen oder reformierten
kurzen bietet ihm eine sonderfahrt mache
mir ist meine einmal dass er anders an
den hut zu bekommen ohne den eimer
können wir hier etwa weg zum schluss
verstehen naja und ab diesem zeitpunkt
muss ich eigentlich nur noch entspannt
ins ziel paddeln
ich bin zwar zweimal fast ertrunken aber
beim eine konstruktion hält weiter an
[Musik]
das weitergeht
langsam viel ein
ich muss schon sagen es fühlt sich gut
an wir sind die letzten meter ich möchte
einfach niemandem danken danke niemand
in diesem moment in diesem moment werde
ich der erste amtierende champion